[Music]
it's too cold to change out here
dang i'm late for mom's rally
[Music]
subway card check you got the house key
yeah
i got it
come on we're going to be late
hey dude i am so filling your suit with
snow
are you still wearing your suit yeah you
know just in case
it's gonna be fine
see this is my favorite part of living
in harlem pop-up street fair
best food in the city awesome music man
this would be great for the last beat i
was working on i should get back into
mixing
yeah it's been a while
what do you think about rio morales are
you going to vote for her
it's still hard to think of mom as a
politician she's been a teacher my whole
life
similar skill sets right growling people
educating them
making sure they don't throw things at
each other
hi i'm brian horton creative director at
insomniac games
we're excited to show you this first
look at gameplay from marvel spider-man
miles morales
our story picks up one year after the
events of the first game
and we find miles new home harlem is in
danger
trouble brews while miles mom rio
morales leads an election rally a war
between the devious energy corporation
roxanne
and the underground a high-tech criminal
army led by the tinkerer
starts to break out in this gameplay
sequence captured on playstation 5
hardware
the underground attacks roxanne sending
the rally into chaos in a fight that
spills onto the braithwaite bridge
where the underground tries to steal
roxanne's experimental energy source
new form let's take a look
let's not shoot each other all right
we're after the new form ignore
everything else
get rid of him then grab as much as you
can carry
[Music]
[Music]
keep him busy
i have to stop this
people are trapped over there i have to
push past these guys
where is he
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
the bus
everybody get out
thank you man those people
they're trapped
i've got an idea
i need something they can cross
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
you